[Music]  for the sauce in hot olive oil by  chopped garlic and diced bread then put  them in a blender add chopped tomatoes  list the skin of red peppers under a hot  grill intensifying the flavor link to  cool then they're easy to peel chop and  add blitz add smoked paprika chili  flakes and roughly chopped almonds a  squeeze of lemon and a dash of sherry  vinegar season blitz again and add olive  oil  this source keeps really well in the  fridge and will intensify in flavor  I love it with simple king prawns just  add olive oil and griddle for 2 minutes  on each side  sweet pepper sauce with grilled prawns  simply delicious and we start from the  bottom to the top so they're across  dinner is making sure this doesn't turn  out dry and is all in their preparation